I just think most people don't want to
work hard enough for what they want in
return I just genuinely believe that I
think everybody wants the stuff it's
just the problem is it's hard work and
you have to give up leisure family time
like you have to give [ __ ] up I mean I
look at my kids right now and I like the
level of disrespect I have for my
children is unbelievable and I make
videos about it
like making fun of them I actually think
I'm doing it on purpose like I think I'm
being competitive with my own children
this is a very flawed thing this is not
good this is me working on my issues i
genuinely do not believe that they could
be as successful because when you are
handed when you grow up on the Upper
East Side and go to private schools and
have a house in the Hamptons you are set
up to not have the hunger or the fight
that it's gonna take because you just
don't know I mean first of all by the
way that's how we are just as human
beings we don't know how tough it is to
be a fly we're like there's like we
don't like we're the Alpha but all I'm
being that serious it's a very funny
thing but like we just take everything
we just take everything for granted